good morning john there are three places
where you can find orange juice in the
grocery store the first one
is inside of oranges second is inside
the orange juice bottles and do you know
where the last one is
you probably do do you it's in the
frozen food aisle
and we have some variants let's just say
presuppositions about the quality of
these juices
getting oranges and squeezing them
that's expensive and hard work and the
best and greenest and healthiest option
getting concentrate that's cheap and
less healthy and worse quality and once
again still involves some work
bottled orange juice on the other hand
is the obvious choice healthier
better greener basically i think orange
juice from concentrate has this
reputation as a subpar
product that is mostly for people who
don't have enough money for the good
stuff
but i think this is wrong and i would
like to make the case for orange juice
from concentrate as the best option
largely due to the fact that if you're
going to drink orange juice which you
probably shouldn't it's equally healthy
equally tasty equally bad for the
environment and a whole lot cheaper
let's start with the taste test this is
the simply orange
which is great it's delicious it's
orange juice you got to get a dorito for
my palate cleanser
i don't teach you that in wine school it
works though this is from concentrate
that's very good that's tasty that
tastes like orange juice orange juice is
good
and here's the fresh squeezed
compared with this oh my god those two
taste exactly the same oh my god it's
delicious
jesus lord i think a lot of people if
you ask them they would say that getting
oranges cutting them open and squeezing
them
is the best and the greenest and the
healthiest option and my friends it is
the best
but shipping oranges all around the
world so that they're available year
round in montana
has a huge environmental impact and
there also was packaging
it's just that the grocery store has
already dealt with it for you one study
showed that the equivalent amount of
fresh-squeezed orange juice required
about nine times more cardboard
than the concentrated stuff now let's
quickly interface with the health
differences and i'll piss some people
off by saying that there are no they are
all
glasses full of sugar there is one way
in which fresco used orange juice is
healthier
than the other kinds it is that it is so
much more work
and it is so much more expensive that
you will consume less of it because
that's the only healthy kind of orange
juice
less it's just candy water you've heard
me give this rant before but i won't
stop doing it by slapping on labels like
rich in vitamin c and no added sugar and
pure squeezed orange juice and not for
concentrate we get the sense that this
is healthy
not just on its own but especially in
comparison
with juice from concentrate and maybe
this is a little bit reinforced by the
taste because i think bottled orange
juice does have a slightly more complex
and less tangy flavor and you'd think
that this is because it's not from
concentrate
but i don't think that's the case i
think they just want the bottle stuff to
taste better
because they make more money on it so
they make it taste better here's the big
lie about orange juice we think that
what we are tasting is what comes out of
the orange
this is demonstrably untrue orange juice
manufacturers want two things
one they want their juice to taste
different from a competitor's juice it
can't just taste the same second though
they want that different taste
to taste the same as itself from bottle
to bottle from month to month from
year to year and that's not something
you can do with oranges so
they flavor it now what you're saying it
doesn't say flavors on the ingredients
it says 100 orange juice well that's
because flavor chemists do magical
things to orange rinds and orange pulp
and they turn the orange into a huge
variety of flavor compounds
so that they can carefully and
consistently select a very particular
flavor
so these are flavored juices but because
they want to maintain that 100 orange
juice label they work their butts off to
create the flavor using only chemicals
that you can make from oranges and so
they both come from the same sugary soup
i don't think there's any reason they
have to taste different now i will say
that concentrating juice is
energetically expensive it does produce
a lot of carbon dioxide so because of
that even though concentrate
is much easier to ship around both
bottled and concentrate have roughly
equal carbon footprint but there's no
doubt in anyone's mind which one has
more packaging and so with less
packaging a lower cost and a longer
shelf life
i'm a concentrate boy especially because
i'm just gonna mix it with homemade soda
water anyway the main thing i want
people to take from this
is don't let people shame you into
buying the more expensive option just
because it's more expensive it doesn't
mean it's better
it's just orange juice it's all bad for
you john
i'll see you on tuesday